this guy Aiden Ross and if you don't
know him he is the number one streamer
on Twitch which is a video game platform
which has crazy following and he's the
number one guy in there I mean this guy
gets bananas could even estimate how
many views he gets a day probably like
50 million views a day like something
just completely completely insane he's a
huge influencer uh and he just tweeted
something very controversial had the
internet lit on fire my God in all caps
he said there are only two genders now
I'm not a I'm not a twitch guy okay I'm
not I'm not a video game guy to any
extent anymore I'm trying to get back in
on it Connor's trying to give me a
little video game 101 situation over
here I can still do Mario Brothers 8-bit
Nintendo uh you know if you warp to four
and warp to eight and you don't lose you
don't die once uh you can beat that game
in about 12 minutes my buddy Mike
Sherman did it in college
um this kid gets about 60 this is per
month oh from the Tweet alone from that
tweet alone just to show you the
influence that this kid has 61 million
views about 525 000 likes about 70 000
retweets 31 000 comments all he did was
say something that we all knew was true
we all knew it
couple years ago we all knew it was true
but now it's controversial and now of
course there's people trying to cancel
him and get his deals cut and everything
else but the point is whether it is some
random video game kid or it's the number
one host in late night or it's me or
it's you we can start putting the pieces
together here we've got the blueprint
people
[Music]
thank you